la plaza San Marcos transformada en Lago
esta mañana en Venecia hay Aqua alta una
inundación causada por un pico de marea
en la laguna un fenómeno que los
habitantes de la ciudad lacustre conocen
bien y que afrontan cada vez más
frecuentemente
en esta época no debería haber Aqua alta
porque antes el periodo de agua alta era
entre octubre y noviembre y ahora miren
lo tenemos a principio de año antes
cuando era joven no era así
es el efecto del cambio climático en
Venecia aguas altas más numerosas pero
también más violentas como esta en 2019
cuando la marea alcanzó 187 centímetros
algo nunca antes visto en medio siglo
[Música]
una inundación cataclísmica que Giovanni
aún recuerda
vive en Venecia desde hace más de 40
años ese día el agua llegó hasta aquí
mire lo invadió todo y aquí se
transformó en una piscina
todos los objetos la nevera todo terminó
en el agua y tuve que votar todo
Tal como Giovanni aquí miles de
habitantes lo perdieron todo
hoy en día ningún residente del centro
histórico de Venecia vive en las
viviendas susceptibles de inundarse
todas las viviendas en el primer piso
que son las más modestas están
despobladas Fueron abandonadas ya que
las familias con pocos ingresos no
cuentan con medios para comprar los
pisos superiores tuvieron que irse a
Tierra Firme
en 70 años la serenísima perdió dos
tercios de sus habitantes
esta farmacia publica la cantidad
actualmente Venecia cuenta con menos de
50.000 residentes
Hola Cuántas visitas tenemos hoy en esta
agencia Inmobiliaria en la cualta es
mencionada regularmente porque el riesgo
de inundación condiciona en parte los
precios del sector inmobiliario las
viviendas en altura cuestan cerca de 30%
más que las otras
en el primer piso hay humedad pero sobre
todo en la cual altas el factor que más
preocupa a los clientes que quieren
comprar una vivienda en Venecia la gente
nos Pregunta cuánto dura si ellos sigue
ocurriendo si la vivienda está expuesta
o no a las inundaciones inundaciones que
la ciudad trata de prevenir
una vez al mes un equipo de la
protección civil controla esta estación
de medición un poco particular
aquí tenemos un tubo que va hasta el
fondo del canal en este tubo hay huecos
para que el agua pueda entrar Ellos nos
da un nivel de agua que no está sometido
a las variaciones causadas por las olas
el objetivo calibrar los instrumentos
que miden el nivel del agua y Tomar nota
de los datos registrados
estamos en cuanto 82 centímetros
perfecto puesto número corresponde esta
cifra corresponde al valor de la marea
medida en este instante ello nos sirve
para poder hacer previsiones en los
próximos días y para garantizar la
navegabilidad en los canales los accesos
a los peatones porque con 85 centímetros
de marea la ciudad empieza a tener
problemas de viabilidad
18 estaciones como esta están ubicadas
en diferentes puntos de la laguna las
informaciones recolectadas son datos
valiosos para entender la evolución de
las mareas en la serenísima Ellos nos da
indicaciones muy importantes sobre la
evolución de la evaluación del nivel del
mar pero también sobre el hundimiento de
la ciudad
cada cinco minutos los datos son
enviados aquí a la sala de operaciones
del centro de prevenciones de las mareas
de la ciudad un equipo de especialistas
analiza las informaciones en especial
sobre el viento la presión atmosférica y
el nivel del agua para emitir
previsiones acabamos de recibir las
informaciones las condiciones para
mañana se degradan bastante indican una
manera de 115 centímetros para pasado
mañana
con los nuevos datos de la marea
empeoramos unos 10 centímetros
para Venecia es enorme es la situación
que teníamos si nada cambia a las 6 a.m
dentro de dos días Tendremos que activar
el sistema
mos el sistema Mouse un conjunto de 78
barreras flotantes que cierran la laguna
en caso de marea superior a 110 cm
en octubre de 2020 fue activado por
primera vez desde entonces sus barreras
fueron elevadas 48 veces
pero para esta medioambientalista esta
infraestructura podría poner en peligro
la diversidad de la laguna de Venecia
en este momento con la Barrera elevada
hay una diferencia de más o menos 40
centímetros entre el nivel del agua aquí
y del otro lado de las barreras
hay que prestar atención y pensar en el
impacto que ello pueda tener en la
calidad del agua pero también en todo el
ecosistema de la laguna
un informe de expertos Internacionales
El hiek menciona el riesgo potencial de
sumergimiento de la ciudad debido al
aumento del nivel de los mares si la
tendencia continúa la serenísima podría
desaparecer bajo las aguas de aquí al
final de siglo